hey everyone and welcome to theories and
Thrones the place where fans can freak
out every Monday morning after each new
episode of Game of Thrones
I'm Leon Aguilera from Entertainment
Tonight and I'm Mike reserve from
GameSpot it finally happened final
season kicked off last night and now
we're gonna talk about it we want to
hear your questions comments and
theories about the biggest twists and
turns
shocking moments plus we've got an
exclusive interview with actor John
Bradley breaking down John and Sam's big
scene so you think that this goes
without saying think so what we selling
you say it yeah
spoiler alert okay spoiler alert we're
gonna be discussing spoilers from the
episode you haven't watched it go watch
it and then come back and watch this but
Mike talk to me about the episode tell
me your general thoughts right now so
the first time I saw it I felt really
emotional all the things I've ever
wanted to see happen on the show are
happening there were so many big moments
and even in in an episode that felt like
it was almost mostly set up for things
to come like it was a lot of people
getting together and setting up future
conflicts for the season it still felt
like there were these huge things that
happened I have some mixed feelings
about it overall but like it's the
beginning of the end and it just it
feels huge you and I were talking about
this there was a lot of setup I would
have loved to have seen a bit more
action but I understand that this is the
episode that we needed to kick off the
season it feels weird that there's only
six episodes right and we spend a whole
episode with with no action we no white
walkers mostly people just arriving at
Winterfell and John and Danny making out
also can we talk about the fact that the
episode was called Winterfell and nobody
knew that yeah I only learned it in a
press release that HBO PR sent out
afterward they revealed the episode
title but on HBO go and HBO now as far
as I can tell it's still just called
m-68 we're starting to get some of your
fam comments in right now Olivia said
the first episode was so good we've got
to agree with you Olivia it was good I
love the fact that we had so many
parallels back to season one you know of
course we had Brandon Jaime's longing
looks at each other
ending was crazy you know it opened with
the small boy running around just like
what that didn't and the pilot yeah and
if you notice like he's trying to get a
better view and Aria kind of moves aside
for him whereas she was the one in the
pilot who's trying to get a better view
and it's like she's not a child anymore
you know like exactly there's a lot of
stuff to glean from this little moment
and then Danny coming into Winterfell
and Sansa saying the North is yours
Winterfell is yours
yeah just like Ned Stark did with from
wrath II like the conversations down in
the crypts yes so many parallels good
little moments I loved it but now that
we've got our initial thoughts out of
the way let's dive into the biggest
question of every Game of Thrones
episode who died it was a surprisingly
light night death wise but I feel like
we should have a moment of silence for a
little Lord umber okay okay
rest in peace little Lord but you scared
the hell out of me when your little
zombie self screeched like a banshee
doesn't always do jump scares but when
they do do jump scares they do really
good they do it really well I was really
concerned with that entire scene I was
really worried that we're gonna lose
tormund just as we got him back but yeah
there he is caught on fire
Wow I loved that we get to see it was a
different symbols it was gruesome but in
the best way possible
the spiral imagery is so cool because it
relates back to the scene where bran
like saw the White Walkers creation yeah
I was like the spirals of rocks coming
out from the tree in the middle it
relates to the imagery of like the seven
gods and the wheel with the spokes Zak I
wonder how that is gonna like play out
come - there must be a point that that
is leading toward because they keep
using this symbolism they keep using
symbols same symbols that we saw in the
cave when they were looking John Janney
for Joe these are like ancient symbols
ages maybe it's the children of the
night and and it's because they were
created by them I don't know I don't
know I don't know but let's rehash the
biggest moments of the night with om
ggot
loved that part so there were so many
reunion it was the episode of as much as
that's been true for the past couple of
seasons right people coming together for
the first time in a long time
and it feels so awkward let's break
these down we had Aria and John re and
Gendry Arya and the Hound John and bran
John and Sam Tyrion and Sansa Jaime and
bran and I think there was Palmer
probably the ones we've got to talk
about re and Gendry yeah that was the
one that had me getting so excited and
some of you guys were already freaking
out about it Sophia says arias smile
when she saw Gendry arriving is so cute
that was when they could have wound up
being more awkward but I felt like they
actually they flared it a little bit
they had a nice rapport
yeah they got down to business with the
that weapon let's talk about this weapon
we have a still of it it looks so
different than with anything that we've
seen Arya wield but at the same time
very similar yeah there's there's a lot
of speculation about this because on one
hand it kind of looks like a spear yeah
and if she has a dragonglass spear I
mean they revealed earlier in the
episode like bran told everyone you know
the night King has Viserion he has an
undead dragon passing which yeah we kind
of just blew past that okay but at the
same time I don't think Arya would I
don't think that would be like her main
concerns yeah he's like I have to have a
spear made so that I can fight this
dragon that's not her eye and also a lot
of people are saying Oh Arya is getting
ready to kill the night King what sky
does she have to that I feel like Arya
is just getting ready to kill Cersei she
would try and kill Cersei with
dragonglass but another thing the weapon
looks like is this attaches yeah it
looks like it's it's it has like maybe
two forms so it's like a staff mm-hmm
like the weapon that she trained with
with the faceless men but then you can
detach it and have like the dagger the
short sword that she's like more used to
fighting yeah so maybe just cover all of
her bases that way I'm excited to see
what this weapon becomes but I'm more
excited to see what becomes of r-n
country I'm sure I want to talk about
Sansa and Tyrion as well because I felt
like those were two characters who kind
of could have had more of a not romantic
but more of a relationship as in as in a
partnership yeah like they're they're
kind of like minded
and in earlier seasons when they were
you know married Sansa wasn't like there
yet yeah Ark she that wasn't who she was
at that point but to see them come
together in this episode and have like
his mutual kind of acknowledgment like
an understanding with one another I
it felt really rewarding I loved seeing
that and I loved especially when you
think about the fact that the last time
they saw each other was when she knocked
out of the purple wedding and kind of
left Tyrion to clean up the mess of
Joffrey's poisoning she didn't have
anything to do with that of course we
know that now but if you watch that
scene - he was trying to get them out of
there before that he didn't know that
was gonna happen
he was like we should go this is you
know like he was thinking of her and
they almost had this little moment and
then everything went down and she bailed
and that made him look even worse yeah I
say he's not holding too much of a car
it was interesting though when she
called him out that he believes that
Cersei is sending the Lannister army up
there she said I thought you should
think you were the cleverest man yeah
it's a nearly dumb moment for Tyrion
although people online have also pointed
out brand kind of gives him a look at
that point so does brand know some like
we do something you know something we
never saw the resolution of Tyrion and
Cersei z-- conversation last season
right when they made that truce so like
maybe Tyrion gave up something in that
agreement that he hasn't went on yet and
that actually I love that theory because
that would explain his ominous like
peeping when Jon and Daniel explained
why he feels like hopefully there's more
going on there I'm literally just
thinking of this right now what if
because Tyrion was talking about the
line of succession and wanted to talk
about that with Dany and she would not
hear it what if he promised Cersei that
her next child could be the successor to
the other because he thinks that dad is
barren which she she maybe yeah holy
crap that could be good that's really
good the last reunion I do want to talk
about is Jon and Arya yes I thought this
is such a pivotal moment it was so great
seeing them together what were your
initial thoughts because we went through
a rollercoaster of emotions watching
that it's so huge because it's been
literally since the pilot of season 1
was the last time drama
each other but not at the same time
among the Starks they had one of the
closest bonds because she she always
felt like an outsider she didn't fit in
with Sansa she wasn't allowed to you
know do our tree or sword training with
the boys and at the same time John was
the outcast being the bastard and so
they had this bond yeah that was like
really clear especially from the books
and from the pilot like he had needle
made for her and it was just like their
hug where he's just like closing his
eyes and and clenched like I thought
they sold her really well I thought they
did a really great job and I did love
the fact that Arya is standing up for
Sansa yeah I thought it was really sweet
when Jon's like even you are defending
her defending our family the dynamics
have have changed yeah and that lines
particularly feels really significant
yes because everybody's about to find
out that John isn't really a stark at
all yeah which family is he going in fan
yeah before we get to that moment let's
talk about John and Danny's dragon
writing date I have thoughts I know you
have a lot of thoughts on this so here's
here's what I'm gonna do I will say
kicking it off I was so excited to see
that John became a dragon rider I wish
it had happened after he realized the
truth about his identity because I feel
like it would have had more of like a
meaning it would have been wait here
exactly
Mike this is your time such it's I've
been waiting for so many years yes for
this to happen it's it's like in the
books it's still not even confirmed that
he's a Turk Arian like that is there in
the books he's still dead like it's such
it's theory and speculation territory
and the way that it happened here was
just anticlimactic like like he said he
didn't know that he was a Targaryen like
Danny was basically like she was
crushing and she was like yeah just hop
up you know why not it's like I could
think of a lot of reasons why not yeah
like it just that was not how I pictured
it going that moment just played off
very light and I guess that was fun but
it's also one of the reasons why I
didn't like the episode it just seemed
to like here we go riding dragon it was
like it was too much mystery to he'll
kill you I don't know there was no there
were no stakes to it yeah yeah and they
like made out in a cave I did like that
moment where everyone was like looking
at them as they made out there it felt
like like a protective yeah
I felt like if you have dogs like you
get it you know that's there I I still
have thoughts about the fact that they
like we're making out in freezing cold I
don't know I don't do well I'm cold so
this just did not look romantic to me or
appealing at all but a really good point
yeah like I don't like being cold so I'm
not about to like can we go inside
please yeah exactly have this whole
castle oh they're trying to keep it hush
I guess and lastly we got to talk about
the fact that John finally knows
something John there's a lot of there's
a lot of things taking him eight seasons
of it here we go what did you think of
that of that conversation I thought that
it it was interesting because we of
course had the big reveal between Dany
Jorah and Sam beforehand expect I did
not expect I was a very surprising and I
was really excited that we got to have
that payoff it felt like it almost when
Sam was in talking to John it felt like
it was like a like a retaliation like
she killed my parents and now you need
to know this drawer the rightfully an
agenda exactly that did that make it
worse for you it made it more
interesting
yeah that's what I think you know it
made it more interesting I are you happy
that it was Sam telling him and not
brand like bran it would have been like
here it is like it can't be brand
because the the scene so the last time
Ned and John saw each other yeah as Ned
was heading south and John was heading
north to join the Nights Watch Ned said
to John you know the next time we see
each other I will tell you the truth
yeah about your mother and by extension
the truth that he's a Targaryen yeah
after he's joined the Nights Watch
that's delivered on that sparked that
conversation had to take place in the
crypt for symbolic for for thematic
reasons bran can't get into the crypt
yeah because it is not wheelchair
accessible there's no ramp down into the
crypts so that conversation had to be
stuck somebody push him inside please he
can come back out in the morning to wait
for Jaime that was like a very weird
silly thing but but I do think the fact
that Sam did seem to have something of
an ulterior motive he was having that
conversation with John made it more
interesting well and also so Mary is
joining us right now
mary says technically john is still a
stark his mother was a stark witch yeah
but the lines of succession
exactly he's definitely has start one
but like Katalin stops being a Tully and
that was just from marriage she's a
she's a stark yeah I just read watched
the pilot she has this conversation with
Ned where she says she still feels like
an outsider and he's like you have five
northern kids what are you talking about
you're a northerner now and her kids
aren't Tully's they're like by that
logic you know King Robb would be a
Tully they're related but yes this is
true but when it comes to the final
scene between John and Sam or the final
scene that we saw between them you and I
were talking about the fact that it
really clearly does seem like he has an
agenda but when I sat down with John
Bradley at the Game of Thrones junket
this is interesting you told me
something completely different take a
look at what he said your mother
was Leon the stop and your father your
real father was Rhaegar Targaryen
you've never been the bastard you are a
gun Targaryen true heir to the Iron
Throne yeah it's not fun thing to tell
no I can't I come from Manchester and
I've never had to tell anybody that but
but I think the thing about that is that
if if Johnny's gonna find out that quite
key piece of information he'd rather
hear it from someone anybody else
because he knows that Sam is the person
who it will be doing it for the right
reasons and he's not got an agenda he's
not trying to cause trouble he's just
telling him because he feels he needs to
know so as far as John goes if he has to
hear that you've been doing that if you
have to hear that you've been doing that
you'd rather over you're loyal and
honest best friend tell you then
you're the true king aegon targaryen vi
of his name protector of the realm all
of him the red woman some credit right
now because she put Jon Snow and
Daenerys together quite the matchmaker
and I've got a red you think the Lord of
Light necessarily cares that Danny is
technically John's aunt
I mean it would be pretty progressive
this is one of the reasons I don't
follow him the whole interesting sir
Davos has become one of John's most
trusted advisors how awkward is that
when that revelation comes to pass we
turn that attack there's a lot of them
when he walks into the room I don't I
don't really want to bring it up I mean
of all the incest in Game of Thrones
that's not so bad is it as a couple of
degrees yeah too bad Isaac oh man
it's interesting seeing John Bradley say
that Sam didn't have an agenda yes he
did that's not how you played it my dude
yeah it seemed like you hadn't it there
was there was a clear linear series of
events that led to you delivering the
news in the way that you did yes he
started off the conversation vice
did you know that Denarius murdered my
sauce it was straight up tilted and
nothing John Bradley says is gonna he
was unbiased with that
not advice he was real biased yeah I
also have a problem with Aegon six of
his name yeah because I mean it's it's
in the show that we talked about this
the the last episode but Rhaegar and
Elia had two kids
mm-hmm one of them was named Marion why
would Liana name her son even even so
the Tower of joy took place after the
sack of King's Landing in Robert's
rebellion so she may have known that
regular and elyes kids were dead so
she's either naming it seems like she's
naming her son after his dead
half-brother would you have wanted him
to be the seventh of his name yeah he's
for one thing he should be the seventh
yes if unless the show version of the
other Aegon has a different name yeah
it's a horde they don't even bring in
the other Aegon yeah or he's he's but
they have her I don't know that they
named him on them yeah you know yeah or
that just give John a different name
like I don't know that he's gonna be
named Aegon in the books that feels like
a weird move yeah but now we want to
hear from all of you because we're gonna
discuss all of your questions comments
and theories you guys have already been
sending us in so many let's kick it off
with Natali
Natalya huh sorry anyways she says now
bran must be the night king I just feel
it what makes you say that
yeah I would like to I would like I mean
I I've been researching this theory yes
because I hate it so much no offense a
lot of people a lot of this love this
theory and they think that this is the
most shocking revelation I have yet to
see one shred of compelling evidence
besides that they they do kind of look
the same when you see their pictures
next to each other that's the most
convincing thing it makes a really good
YouTube though you know very they have a
very similar like structure of outfit so
maybe I just don't ever change the
reason why I don't believe that is it I
don't see them the thematic or the
narrative purpose like me that
invalidates brands entire story arc and
that just feels cheap I don't I'm with
you taking it back to little Lord umber
Megan's
said the sustained screaming went on a
little too long fair fair we saw in the
premiere screaming it echoed fresh feel
like I feel like the people who who are
saying that I went on too long or maybe
the people who jumped out of their seats
get a little scared under it's
understandable yeah
next up we have a comment from aks who
said there were so many highs but
honestly the most amazing instant was
Jamie's facial expression changing from
relief to shock the second he saw a
brand that was gold
I loved that moment it was such a cool
way to end the episode I have I have a
theory
that I would love to see come true which
is that Jamie who obviously pushed bran
out of Windows 7 seasons ago will wind
up pushing brand around in his
wheelchair somebody needs to get brand
inside he's gonna catch a cold
like I know you're the three-eyed Raven
that does not make you immune from germs
I mean but he can see his future when
he's getting sick that's I guess he
could just go inside at the right time
it is interesting when we saw the
trailer for next week's episode of
course bringing back the fact that Jamie
is the Kingslayer who killed Danny's
father yes and it's gonna be a very
interesting rippling effect you had said
earlier they're gonna be like two people
who are stoked Jamie at Winterfell and
everyone else yeah it's like it's like
Tyrion and brand apparently are cool
with him Brian will be excited yes--that
too and then just like side I what
people don't know also that he pushed
brand like that's not a revelation that
ever came out in a big way and that's
the kind of thing that the show tends to
kind of blow past at this point yeah I'm
hoping they take a little moment for
John to be pissed off on brans behalf
because bran is apparently incapable of
feeling emotions at this point yeah a
little bit while we're on the subject of
Jamie Earl says Cersei isn't pregnant
and I still when when you're on look to
nurses I'm gonna put a prince in your
belly
pardon me wanted to screen their
priorities be something in there or
gurgles I think it's really quite I
think it's one of the more clever things
the show has done because there are
legitimately multiple ways to read that
yeah and like the expression on her face
when he says that if she can't if she's
not pregnant that's one way but then
she's hoping that maybe it'll fulfil her
lie right if she's if she is pregnant
she has sense Qyburn to send brawn to
kill Jaime and Tyrion I feel like
finally having sex with Iran could have
been a play yeah to make your own think
that the kid is his when it's fine if
she is pregnant if she is pressed uterus
of lies man that's gonna start right now
okay so Tamara agrees with you with the
dragon ride she says the dragon ride was
too much like the neverending story for
me I think that's such a perfect
comparison yeah and she said and then
did she go from oh no my dragons are
starving - lets deplete them further by
writing them for fun I know like the the
whole impetus for them going to see the
Dragons is they're not eating you're not
eating I don't like the north yeah so
let's have like a farcical dragon ride
like the middle of nowhere my favorite
comments I saw was oh there's definitely
a dragon ride roller coaster coming
somewhere at some theme park that's that
scene felt like something that was
designed to be turned into a theme park
ride Harry Potter right that I've been
on at Universal right I know it's not a
good thing though no no I'm sure Megan
says I wonder how much of the buildings
and Game of Thrones are wheelchair
accessible yeah none yeah not
eighty-eight compliant no I don't know
Doran seems kind of flat go to Dorne
right well because of Dorian it is and
his goat yeah I wonder if bran will
retire to Dorne to cave north of the
wall
become a tree person JimBob says has
anyone thought that the symbols actually
look like the Targaryen sigil
yes I saw that too especially when it's
lit on fire yes it looks like the curled
red dragon and I don't I wonder whether
that's just kind of parallel symbolism
going on like the you know the visual
design yeah being clever or if there's
something more to that because we still
don't I've talked about this a lot but
we still do not know what the purpose or
the goal of the White Walkers is yes we
we've talked about that quite a bit it's
the fact that we don't want them to just
be mindless yeah evil creatures there's
so much complexity on the show there's
been so many great villains and then we
have just these like iceberg
coming down from the north to wreak
havoc and destruction and that's boring
mm-hmm Carter says can we talk about how
fast Jamie got to Winterfell I was
thinking the exact same thing they tried
to show him that he has a beard and it
took a while but yeah they've said that
it's at least a month's ride from King's
Landing to Winterfell I mean we all know
that the timeline on on this on this
series is not I think they I think they
put an effort into making it seem like
time had passed there were some little
cues like his beard has grown out so I
think you can make the argument and he
was heading from King's Landing probably
slightly after cause he'd already he was
talking with the bannermen when he had
that conversation resources so he had
called the bannermen Sean and Danny
start heading up I think they said did
they say they were taking a boat to
white Harbor they took their own route
he just went up the Kings Road but at
the same time Theon who was at
Dragonstone apparently took the same
amount of time to head to King's Landing
which is right across the bay yeah that
everybody else took to travel you a
month's distance up to King's Landing I
would love just at the bottom of the
screen just give us a date translator
yes
able Kedar says how do you think Danny
will react to John being the true heir
that's the big question that is a big
question I don't know I hope we get that
answer next week
we must if they prolong it any more than
that I will scream it has to be it has
to be something that they deal with
before the battle because right now the
pieces are all falling into place to
make thee a complete like everybody's
coming to Winterfell
Cersei betrayed them whatever like
they're all prepared it's too easy for
for John and Danny to have met over one
season forged this bond and live happily
ever after
I don't want a happily ever after as
much as I would love to have it I need
the ending to be more bitter than sweet
yeah it would feel it would feel like
fanservice yeah it'd feel like
fanservice which the show already feels
like a lot of the time in these later
seasons the other on the other side of
that I hope that they don't go too far
in the other direction where where
suddenly Danny and John are just
instantly at war yeah you know like
there is a more it's more of a gray area
there's a more complex understanding
that they need to reach I hope they
don't do so easily but I do hope that
they do so because Targaryen Targaryen
's brother and sister have you know
they've gone the Conqueror you know in
the history of Westeros I think was
married to both of his sisters so there
is precedent for that he had a favorite
sister sure yeah
Game of Thrones has done more to
normalize incest in pop culture than any
anything else in history so why stop now
yeah it's just as aunt and nephew Sophia
wants to know and I know you have a lot
of thoughts on this what do you think
about the golden company oh you mean the
company that did not have elephants I
one of my favorite lines from the
episode was Cersei going I was told
there would be elephants me to Cersei I
related to that a lot I don't know we
haven't really been interested like
Harry Strickland I think had one line if
you guys watched our last episode then
you know that I'm still hoping that the
golden company will matter more than
just being more sorts for Cersei their
book back story there's a lot of stuff
about another Targaryen that was
spirited away to Essos and has been
raised and trained as part of the golden
company for years and years
coming back to Westeros and I don't know
do you feel like they could still fit
that in after not addressing it in the
there's only five episodes I feel like
if they fit it in now it'll be messy
it won't be clean and I just do not
think that they have the time for it I
mean a lot that I feel like the past two
seasons have felt so rushed like hmm
you're on it I think it's a good example
yours is a perfect example he seems
cartoonish he just seems like there's no
character we're supposed to revere him
and I just don't feel it circling back
though to the elephants had we seen them
and not seen ghosts ill I would've been
so pissed right they have elephant
budget or they don't have ghosts but I'd
like 19 reunions and you couldn't put
ghosts in there could they have like cut
that dragon ride like in half five
minutes Sean's like I don't know so long
we're asking him in a season in an
episode
direwolf he's like it's real big it's
another thing that in the books feels so
important so crucial to John's identity
yeah and like if you only watch the show
you may have forgotten that John has a
direwolf at all last time you saw him
was the beginning of season also it's
clear that John is not a dog lover
because yeah the second you go home you
find your dog yeah you go hug your dog
my dog everywhere
yeah not going you know ghost hop up
onto this dragon with me that would've
been amazing I went to there were a
couple more things that you saw
afterwards online that you wanted to
talk about they didn't notice originally
in the episode which I thought was
amazing were you on reddit yes I mean of
course I wasn't I live on reddit um one
of my favorite things was learning the
the fate of Ed Sheeran's character from
from season one yeah
or season 7 I think it was the first
episode of season 7 though if you
remember ed Sheeran had a weird cameo
that a lot of people hated so the women
that bran is boiling with in this
episode or having this this conversation
kind of in the background about a
Lannister soldier and Eddie who had
ginger hair and got his face melted off
by a dragon and has no eyelids so a lot
of people have taken that to be a
reference to Ed Sheeran's character ed
and that is glorious I'm not sorry my
other favorite thing for it's always
sunny fans Rob McElhenney who plays Mac
on it's always sunny was in the episode
you know he's the one that got the arrow
that shot through and came out his eye
yeah when Theon is rescuing Yara which
isn't that's just everything because
another thing that just like it happened
it happened he is one of the Ironborn
soldiers who is on the deck of the ship
who gets killed so hard and I would
never have known this but Rob posted it
on it we're gonna show you the photo but
we were worried it was a little goofy
it's pretty graphic awesome but I think
we're gonna end it there for right now
thank you all so much for tuning in and
be sure to join us for theories and
Thrones every Monday
at 8 a.m. West Coast 11 a.m. east coast
for the next five episodes we're gonna
be breaking down every episode of every
on the final season we're going to
include your comments thoughts and
theories about the final season as
always as always plus you can always
tweet us your thoughts anytime you'd
like we will respond thanks again for
watching theories and Thrones and we'll
see you next time
[Music]